everyone will converge in the middle of  the map and it will a be with a lot  about gateman here the saddle drafter  already and it looks like throwing down  some foundations over there definitely  gonna be making pikes and most likely  crossbows and maybe even guns oh no what  are they gonna be able to do to take you  know all the teams working it like my  mama was chase me when I was a kid it  just straight outta here or being raised  you with dragon gone from an underdog to  backbone to hop drive eliminated with  the yes and he's going in for  oh my god like they're stabbing each  other this is Abbot  they're all going in we're at playing  team in the middle someone this isn't  your normal battle royale no this is the  survival fittest  you